Please welcome Adam Lambert!
(audience cheering)
Hi, Adam!
Hi, Drew!
How are you?
Great, how are you?
It's funny too 'cause you wouldn't know it,
but we're 3,000 miles apart.
This is magic of television, 2021 style.
I love it, I love it.
This has been, and we didn't know
that we were wearing the exact same like, color palette.
We are like matching.
Look at this, it's like a grayish fantasy.
That being said, I am freaking out over your shoes.
It was the first thing I noticed.
I was like, "Oh, whoa, those are good shoes."
They're Rick Owens and I like have them
in like seven different colors
because I'm obsessed with them.
I mean, you really do have such phenomenal style
and I've been watching-
Thank you.
your YouTube videos
for your beauty tutorials.
Yeah, that's new, a new venture.
Tell me all about this 'cause I think
this is really awesome.
Well, I mean, you know, I've always worn makeup
and I remember being like a kid in the 90s
and it was so taboo for a boy to wear makeup
except for a couple of rock stars that I saw on television.
I remember seeing Dave Navarro on TV
in his eyeliner, remember?
Of course!
His eyeliner and his nail polish.
And I was like, "That is so cool. That's so me."
And I was always playing with makeup at home
and doing it on other people.
And then I just slowly got into it
in my twenties more and more,
and I actually worked as a makeup artist for a few years
before I've ever gotten any gigs.
So I made a choice at some point around like 24.
I'm like, "Okay, I actually, I want to be a performer."
So I kind of moved away from makeup,
but it was like a side gig for me.
It was my being a waiter before anything happened.
And you're so good at it.
Thanks!
I'm going to turn it over to my co-host, Ruby.
Hello.
I think you have some beauty questions actually.
We do. I do. So it is like rapid-fire.
So I'm going to ask them really quickly.
So you're going to have to give me an answer right away
within 60 seconds.
You ready?
Yes!
I'm ready. (laughs)
I'm ready!
Adam, let's do this together.
60 seconds, so I'm going to read them really quickly,
Adam, what's the secret to a smokey eye?
Use your fingers after the liner.
Yes! Drew, what's one makeup product
that's always in your purse?
Ah, concealer!
Adam, what's hotter for a night out,
red lip or high-shine gloss?
It depends on the eye. Smokey eye, nude lip,
light eye, red lip.
Love it, love it!
Agreed, agree.
Drew, how can I prevent mascara from clumping?
Use Flower Beauty's Warrior Princess Mascara,
it never flakes it, does it?
Absolutely!
(audience cheers)
I will send you some, Adam.
Okay, great.
Adam, how often should I be washing my makeup brushes?
I mean, they say once a week but I'm terrible at it.
So wash them more than me, please.
Okay. Drew, what is one beauty product worth splurging on?
(dramatic music)
I say more skincare than makeup.
Yes.
If you're going to spend money, do it on skincare.
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Love it, love it!
I agree.
Now I want to talk about "Clash of the Cover Bands."
Now this is a Jimmy Fallon produced show,
with his production company and I watched the first episode.
First of all, tWitch, who's so amazing, is the MC
and then, oh my gosh, Meghan Trainor, hello?
Amazing.
One of my favorite
all-time Nantucket girl, which is the coolest.
And I was watching it and I'd like to say something to you,
which is,
I'm so glad that you gave constructive criticism
because I feel like when I'm watching those shows,
everybody wants a boost of confidence, very, very kind.
But what I really want to see is help and guidance.
Yeah! (laughs) Yeah.
How do you have the confidence
because your constructive criticism is really good.
What is your process?
Well, I mean, I'm an Aquarius,
so I am like super analytical.
I'm always trying to break things down.
So as I'm watching, I'm breaking it down.
But then once I have those ideas
of what could be improved upon,
I also put myself in their shoes.
I was a contestant on a singing show.
You gotta wrap it up in a nice way,
in a way that doesn't offend them,
in a way that doesn't throw them off guard,
in a way that feels helpful.
So I think it's using that empathy with the analyzation.
That's the process.
You know, the other thing is that we had some real talent
on the stage. I mean, there were some of the acts
that we were, the three of us were just blown away by,
I mean, real, real iconic impressions,
impersonations that we're talking about.
Like, people that you do, like a double-take
and you're like, "Wait, what?"
You know? And it wasn't until they got a little closer
to the edge of the stage that you went,
"Okay, you're not a Britney Spears."
"You're not J.Lo."
I mean, it was like, it was wild.
Is it true that you used to work on a cruise ship?
(laughs) That was one job of many jobs
and yeah, I was like 19.
So I worked on it for 10 months,
still a teenager when I got hired.
And it was just, it was a very surreal experience.
It was sort of a little bit like a college dorm.
It was performing for a lot of senior citizens
on this cruise line,
(Drew laughs)
it was kind of geared towards them.
But they loved the show, the audiences loved the show
and I got to sing a lot of amazing music and see the world.
So it was a lot of fun.
And where was your favorite place
that you got taken on this beautiful odyssey?
(laughs) Well, I mean that was,
well, one thing about it is I was 19.
I had just come out of the closet.
I was like raring to go out and party and socialize,
but being an older cruise line clientele,
we would get to a port at 6:00 AM and leave at 6:00 PM.
So I could never go out. (laughs)
It was like day trips only.
We actually, we were in New York on September 7th of 2000...
Oh, really?
Yeah.
And we were stranded outside of Boston
during the whole thing.
And it was a wild time. It was really crazy.
I'm going to parlay this right over to Ruby
because you have a question that when I heard
what your question was,
I was so curious for the answer. So please ask it.
Sure.
So my question, Adam,
is if you were not a singer songwriter,
what would you be doing with your life?
What else would you be doing?
You know, I've always been a creative person.
I would probably go into some sort of design.
I would make clothes or makeup,
or like interiors or something, something visual.
I love that.
(upbeat music)